la loi antidopage la france voudrait
bien prendre la tête du mouvement marie
george buffet a préparé le terrain avec
une concertation tout azimut
a priori son projet plutôt bien
accueilli mais la discussion s'est tenue
à l'assemblée risquent de se prolonger
plus de 80 amendements ont été déposés
valérie patton et alain thomas
prévention et lutte contre le dopage le
gouvernement veut faire vie ce soir
devant les députés tout acquis à sa
cause
la ministre marie george buffet a plaidé
pour redonner au sport sa dimension
humaine loin de nous accommoder du
dopage n'est dopage à plusieurs vitesses
il nous faut au contraire en chercher
les fosses profondes et nous y attaquer
sans faiblesse ce projet de loi durcit
après les scandales du tour de france
l'été dernier
créer une sorte de hautes autorités du
sport principale nouveauté le cpl des
comités de prévention et de lutte contre
le dopage indépendant son pouvoir de
contrôle et renforcé pour les dopeurs
les sanctions sont plus lourdes jusqu'à
sept ans de prison et des amendes de 500
mille à un million de francs
enfin un dispositif d' alerte médicale
et un suivi plus régulier des sportifs
implique davantage les médecins du sport
ce texte en avance sur les pays
européens suscite un large consensus
mais les députés de l'opposition
réclament une plus grande harmonisation
européenne et souhaite que soit lever
certaines ambiguïtés
c'est à dire qu'il faut aider le
mouvement sportif mais aussi substitué
les adrets notamment pour la prévention
pour l'éducation pour les sanctions
également il faut faire très attention
ce que le médecin qu'on ne soit pas
transformé en procureur mais reste le
secours et le confident du sportif en
difficulté pour une harmonisation des
législations la ministre des sports
souhaite tenir une réunion avec ses
homologues européens avant la conférence
mondiale du comité international
olympique
tous les groupes ont annoncé qu'il
voterait le texte cette nuit à
l'exception du rpr qui a décidé de
s'abstenir